All right.
We're in the home stretch of
this first, I guess we could
have called almost experimental
section, but
hopefully it's been working
out decently.
So we're on number 17.
And it says, if a plus 2, times
x plus 1 is equal to s,
what is x plus 1 in
terms of s and a?
So x plus 1 is essentially
equal to what?
So let's just take this
equation-- so what happens if
we subtract a from both sides?
Well, we get 2 times x plus
1 is equal to s minus a.
I just subtracted a
from both sides.
Let me switch colors.
And then if we divide both sides
by 2, we get x plus 1 is
equal to s minus a over 2.
And I think we're done.
That's it.
That was choice B.
It was actually surprising to
see a problem that took so
little time this late in the
test. Because they normally
get kind of harder as
you go through.
And I guess the reason why this
is a little tricky is a
lot of people's initial
motivation would be to try to
solve for x, and then
try to figure out
what x plus 1 equals.
But the trick is to just not
break apart this x plus 1.
I mean, you could kind of view
this as a variable, once
again, like a couple of problems
ago, where you have
to avoid distributing
this 2 out.
If you just keep it as x plus 1
and you solve for x plus 1,
you get very quickly to
s minus a over 2,
which is choice B.
The next problem, number 18.
We are in the home stretch.
And this is normally when
the problems get on
the difficult side.
So let me clear this, because
it looks like it might take
some space.
The shaded region above,
so let me draw the
shaded region above.
That's the y-axis-- oh man, I
want to draw it straight, but
anyway, I'll deal.
I'll deal.
You can't always be perfect.
So this is the y-axis,
this is the x-axis.
And then I have this neat
looking curve that looks
something like this.
The curve keeps going.
Let's see, it draws
off some points.
So it's like 1, 2, 3, 4.
And it draws this boundary
line here.
It draws this boundary
line at 4.
So it's like this.
And then they shade the region,
and I have a feeling
you're going to ask about
the shaded region.
Actually, let me-- because
I'm going to use
the shaded in tools.
Let me make sure that I don't
end up filling up the whole
screen, so I want to make sure
that I close all the gaps.
So now let me use the
shaded in tool.
Ah, there, it worked out.
All right, so what
do they say?
The shaded region in the figure
above is bounded by the
x-axis, that's this.
The line x equals 4,
that's this line.
And the graph y equals f of x.
That's this, that's
the brown line.
y is equal to-- I never use
grey, maybe I should use grey.
I don't like grey.
Anyway, green.
If the point a, b lies in the
shaded region-- so we don't
know where.
It's some place in this-- let
me use a darker color.
Let me use navy blue.
This point a, b is some place
in the shaded region.
Which of the following
must be true?
And they have choice number
one-- now I have to use a
lighter color-- choice number
one is that a is less than or
equal to 4.
Choice number two is that b is
less than or equal to a.
And choice number three is
that b is less than or
equal to f of a.
Interesting.
So we know that a, b is in this
grey region, so it's some
place around there.
So if that's a, b, so that means
that this point-- and
it's not exact. a, b could have
been anywhere in this
grey area, but let's say
that this point is a.
And we know that this
point is b.
So we know a couple of things.
We know that a is some place
between 0 and 4.
So that means that a is less
than or equal to 4, because it
could be 4, because we're
including the boundary.
So this is correct.
We know this is true.
Let's see.
We also know-- well, we don't
know whether-- let's see, b is
less than a.
How can we come to
that conclusion?
Because if we had the point that
was, like, right-- well,
even where it's here, but
let's say that this
point was our a, b.
And I mean, just eyeballing it,
just looking at the graph,
it just looks-- I mean,
we don't know.
It looks like b in this
situation would
be larger than a.
So I definitely don't think we
can make that conclusion.
At least, there's no obvious way
to make that conclusion.
Because we don't know what f
of x is. f of x could be
really steep and have a really
high slope, in which case, b
would grow faster than a at
this point earlier on.
So I don't think that
this is right.
So this is not right.
And then let's see, is
b less than f of a?
So what is f of a?
If this is point a,
what is f of a?
Well, f of a is going
to be right here.
This is f of a.
And no matter where you draw it,
b is definitely going to
be less than f of a.
If you picked this as our point,
and if you said that
this is b, and that this is a,
then this would be f of a in
bloody red.
And b would still be less than
f of a, because b is in the
shaded region that is less
than f of a, essentially.
So we also know that this
last term is correct.
Hopefully that makes sense.
If this one doesn't make
sense, I want you to
experiment with it.
And you'll see.
But we're essentially saying
that the point is all the y
values less than f of x.
This is the shaded region
essentially.
So let's see, what
choice is that?
One and three.
One and three only,
that is choice D.
D as in dog.
Number 19.
I don't know if we're going
to have time for this.
I might have to do it
in the next video.
Actually, let's just do it in
the next video, because I have
two more problems, and I'm going
to have to have another
video no matter what.
So I'll see you in
the next video.